To return the average score, I want to calculate the total, and divide by the
number of scores. I already have a method to calculate the total. I can call
some scores, and divide by current size. But I'm not sure that this is what I
want to return. We had that issue before, where if current size was zero, we
ran into errors. So I'll need to handle that case. If the current size is zero,
I want to return zero, otherwise, it's safe to calculate the actual average. We
need to actually return the average. Compile. And now, if I enter the scores
that I entered before, I'll get the total, and also the average. But what if I
wanted to remove the lowest score? We haven't talked about removing items from
a partially filled array, yet. Kai will talk about that, now.